[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار زار الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مدينه سيفاستوبل في
شبه جزيره القرمه ونشرت وسائل اعلام روسيه
صورا لفوتين خلال افتتاحه مدرسه ومركزا
للفنون في المدينه وتزامنت زياره مع حلول
ذكرى التاسعه لضم شبه الجزيره الى روسيا
في المقابل قال اندريه ماك مدير مكتب
الرئيس الاوكراني ان شبه جزيره القرم ارض
الاوكرانيه وانها ستستعيدها بالدعم الدولي
واضاف في تغريده انه قبل تسع سنوات استولت
القوات الروسيه على القرمه وضمتها بشكل
غير قانوني
قالت المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخارف ان انهاء العقوبات والملاحقات
القضائيه ضد روسيا هو اساس اي تسويه في
اوكرانيا
هذا ويجري الرئيس الصيني زياره مرتقبه الى
موسكو غدا الاثنين حيث يتوقع نيناقش مع
الرئيس الروسي المبادره الصينيه للتسويه
اما على الصعيد الاوكراني فيتوقع اجراء
اتصال بين الرئيس الصيني ونظيره الاوكراني
وهو ما رحبت به واشنطن
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه حين القوات
الروسيه قصفت بوابل من المسيرات المتفجره
مناطق عده في البلاد وصل بعضها الى منطقه
الفيف غربا لاول مره منذ شهور
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
المباحثات التي قادتها بلاده نجحت في
تمديد اتفاقيه الحبوب بين الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني
وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه انها ابلغت
الاطراف المشاركه في اتفاق الحبوب بتمديده
لستين يوما فقط حتى تتاكد من تنفيذه
بالكامل وكانت الامم المتحده اعلنت تمديد
الاتفاق واحثت جميع الاطراف على الالتزام
به لانه ساهم في تحقيق الاستقرار في
الاسواق العالميه
اعلنا الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
تشامب انه سوف يتعرض للاعتقال يوم
الثلاثاء المقبل داعيا انصاره للاحتجاج
وقد نفى الادعاء العام في منهات
بموعد توجيه التهامي او الاعتقال بينما
تحدثت التقارير عن عدم التوافق بين القضاء
ومحامي تشام لتسليم نفسه بدوره تهم رئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكيه المدعي العامه
باستخدام السلطه للانتقام السياسي من
هذا رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق
عمران خان الى مقر اقامته في لاهور بعد
اثبات حضوره امام المحكمه في القضيه
الخاصه بالتصرف في هدايا الثمينه ووصل خان
الى منزله بعد تاجيد القضيه الى الثلاثين
من الشهر الجاري
وكانت مواجهات قد اندلعت بين الشرطه
ومتظاهرين مؤيدين لرئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق في محيط المجمع القضائي
في العاصمه
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء